(gentle upbeat music)
- The world's most pressing
issues demand our attention,
and innovation is a way for
us to think outside of the box
and come up with solutions
in a way that is faster,
more efficient, and allows
us to solve problems
with greater success.
YSPH is really unique
in that it's one of the only
schools of public health
that has a dedicated
program for innovation.
So InnovateHealth Yale was
started in 2013 at YSPH,
and it's a way to really
provide students, alumni,
and faculty who are
interested in challenging
and changing public health issues.
And we're part of this vibrant
Yale innovation ecosystem
that has partners from across campus,
the School of Management, Yale Ventures,
and the Tsai Center for
Innovative Thinking,
as well as program partners
at the School of the Environment
and the Graduate School
of Arts and Sciences.
And it's a very supportive environment
because we have funding, mentorship,
and a collaborative community
across Yale University
to bounce ideas off of, meet partners.
And that's really how we come
up with a lot of our creative
and innovative solutions.
InnovateHealth Yale has been involved
in so many interesting and
groundbreaking innovations,
and I'm happy to provide some examples.
So KovaDx was the winner of
the 2020 Rita Wilson Prize
that was supported by InnovateHealth Yale,
and they use machine learning
to analyze red blood cells
to help screen for disease.
And they've had a lot
of interesting impacts,
particularly in sickle cell,
and now they're expanding to
other types of blood diseases.
Brio is a mental health platform
that uses community-led models of care,
and it's really innovative
because they are helping
to support mental health
and wellbeing, but are really taking in
the expertise of the local
communities where they work.
So to date, InnovateHealth
Yale has supported
over 52 startups operating
in over 30 countries,
and we've given out about
$400,000 in impact grants.
And the really exciting thing
is that we've seen our alumni go on
to continue to be supported by Techstars,
the Chan Zuckerberg Initiative, Google,
and leading venture capital firms.
(gentle upbeat music)
(gentle upbeat music fades)